a new report says that president Trump's
oldest son knew a year ago that Russia's
government was trying to help his
father's campaign the New York Times
says Donald Trump jr. was told of
Russia's agenda in an email sent to a
set up to set up a campaign meeting with
a Russian lawyer Margaret Brennan is at
the White House with the next move for
Donald Trump jr. Margaret good morning
good morning well Donald Trump jr. has
hired a lawyer to help with all matters
related to Russia and this ongoing FBI
investigation though he has not been
formally asked Trump jr. said he is
willing to cooperate with Congress
rest assured Donald Trump jr. will be
somebody that we want to talk to Senate
Intelligence Committee vice-chairman
Mark Warner called for Donald Trump jr.
to share details of his meeting last
June with Natalia vessel net skya a
Russian national who indicated she could
offer damaging information on Hillary
Clinton according to the New York Times
Donald Trump jr. had been explicitly
told via email that the meaning was part
of a Russian government effort to aid
his father's candidacy in response to
that allegation a lawyer for Trump jr.
told CBS News quote this is much ado
about nothing Don jr. had no knowledge
as to what specific information if any
would be discussed his father knew
nothing about it
this is the first time the public has
seen clear evidence that senior level
officials of the Trump campaign met with
potentially an agent of a foreign
government to try to obtain information
that was discredit Hillary Clinton
Donald Trump Jr's account has evolved
since the meeting was first revealed by
the New York Times on Saturday Trump jr.
told The Times the meeting was primarily
about adoptions later he admitted
damaging information about Hillary
Clinton was the pretext for the
encounter he insisted it was nothing
unusual posting a sarcastic Twitter
message obviously I'm the first person
on a campaign to ever take a meeting to
hear info about an opponent the
revelation about the meeting contradicts
several accounts from White House
officials this was Kellyanne Conway on
Face the Nation in December did anyone
involved in the Trump campaign have any
contact with Russians trying to meddle
with the election absolutely
and I discussed that with the
president-elect just last night those
conversations never happened in February
when the president was asked directly
whether anyone on the campaign had
contacts with the Russians
he answered for himself only well I had
nothing to do with it former Trump
campaign chair Paul mana for as well as
the president's son-in-law Jared Kushner
were also present in that meeting
something that Kushner's representatives
say he initially overlooked but did
recently disclosed as part of a
background check for his security
clearance
Charlie thanks Margaret